if you're a comedian struggling to stay
productive and motivated during these
uncertain times
this is the video you've been looking
for hi breath
what's up hot breath verse welcome to
hot breath the show where you learn
comedy from the pros
i am comedian and founder of the hop
breath comedy network
joel byers here to bring you the top
five quarantine tips from some of our
most
popular episodes if you're struggling to
find motivation or
inspiration during this time let this
channel be your
breath of fresh air if you will as we've
interviewed over 200 comics about the
craft of comedy
and will now start to compile these
interviews into helpful quick
tips like you're getting today all about
quarantine so congratulations on finding
this video
it was meant to be and now you get
exclusive tips from
dan soder jeremiah watkins beth stelling
dusty slay
and nate bargatzi stay tuned till the
end because i'll have an extra tip for
how you can start to get involved in
these q and a's like the ones you're
watching here
people are telling you to try to make
the most out of quarantine time but
if you're a comic and you don't know how
to edit like use photoshop or final cut
do the online tutorials i mean they're
they're kind of grueling sometimes and
you have to really force yourself
to to kind of sit through it and and
learn but it's something that will help
you
long long into your career after this is
all said and done with
my best advice for comedians going
through this right now try to find the
way to scratch that
itch without being able to do stand up
if you can do that via zoom shows
or you know online shows i would say do
that i don't
necessarily like them but i'm lucky
enough that i can wait for audiences to
come back
but i would also say you don't have to
release everything you do
i think we're in this weird age where
everyone wants to show you how busy they
are without actually concentrating on
making something that's really good
well i would say now is a good time to
create
social media content but not but but you
have the free time to do
good stuff right i feel like everybody
in the beginning
was just slamming stuff out because they
were like oh i got to get it out i got
to be the first one to talk about the
quarantine
i say you can forget all about the
quarantine
and just do the content that you've
always wanted to do
like now's your time remember that your
words are a magnet so what you say will
draw certain people to you and you need
to make sure that those are the type of
people you want drawn
to you uh you don't have to do
everything every podcast ever you know
like
don't go on something that has fans that
you don't think are gonna love what you
do or you don't want liking what you do
jokes matter i i think no matter who you
are so
to say that you know to say things that
whether you're influential or not but
especially if you're influential and
have a lot of followers like
they're not just jokes like what you say
matters
you know the only thing we have is
performing live that i have
and so that all got taken and so it's
gone
and you know there's other ways to do
stuff to be creative
if it's a newer comic it's like because
the problem is like you just have no
uh way to go be funny in a way
and so doing a lot of these doing a lot
of interviews or something
or like where i'm at least talking and
having to be funny and doing friends
podcasts
that's a good that's a good thing to do
during this time even if you do one a
week just to kind of keep your chops
like you know
if you're newer or something it's like
try to start a podcast try to start
something
think of you know find some way to be
creative be ready so when it's time to
come back
you're you know ready to go there you go
hot brother
and sister i hope you found those tips
helpful my most helpful tip is from
jeremiah watkins
that inspired me to start editing videos
like these i'd love to know what your
favorite tips were
comment in the section below with your
favorite tips from this video
and the one with the most likes will get
a shout out on our next video
and if you'd like to watch these q and
a's live go into the show description
and join our facebook group where we're
doing these weekly q and a's
daily writing clubs and much more with
comics from around the world
i hope to see you there
you